l'essere umano è l'unico essere vivente
al mondo che non si vuole bene Buonasera
come state Quanti di voi sono felici di
essere qui
[Applauso]
Che bello è la prima volta che ho
davanti a me una platea di persone che
sono venuta ad ascoltarmi parlare di
sicurezza sul lavoro e Sì di solito i
lavoratori vengono spinti a forza nelle
aule in cui insegno e quando mi presento
e chiedo loro cosa ci facciano mi
rispondono mi ci hanno mandato
Ecco questa è la fotografia che ancora
oggi possiamo fare la cultura della
sicurezza in Italia Ma cosa c'è dentro
il riquadro di questa fotografia ve lo
dico subito per me cultura della
sicurezza è uno stile di vita non si
tratta di un manuale con dati nozioni
informazioni lo vedo piuttosto come un
casco da moto che se sai come usarlo e
sai che è importante quando guidi lo
indossi e sai che ti salverà la vita
Adesso voglio fare con voi una
fotografia la cultura della sicurezza Ci
state sorridete
Ecco avete fatto la stessa faccia di
tutti quei lavoratori che non
immaginavano di subire un infortunio
non ne vedono il rischio non sono
consapevoli perché abbiamo sempre fatto
così figurati se capita a me
Adesso vi racconto un particolare la
sicurezza sul lavoro è tanto scontata
quanto è vecchia ma quanto è vecchia
Quanti di voi sanno da quando si è
cominciato a fare sicurezza sul lavoro
Lo sapevo anche se lo chiedete ai
lavoratori vi risponderanno da vent'anni
dall'81 Da quando hanno iniziato a
mettere le multe
e invece si è cominciato a parlare
seriamente di sicurezza sul lavoro già
dagli anni 50
vi racconto
invece che
vorrei farvi alcune domande guarda vi
faccio delle domande e potete
rispondermi anche solo alzando la mano e
Puntando il dito verso l'alto Oppure
verso il basso vi ho fatto anche un
disegnino vedete così è più semplice
Allora prima domanda Secondo voi dagli
anni 50 ad oggi le leggi e le regole
della sicurezza sono diminuite o sono
aumentate
e i dispositivi di sicurezza sono
diminuiti o sono aumentati
esatto e i corsi di formazione sulla
sicurezza
bravissimi sapevo che avreste risposto
correttamente ma nonostante tutte queste
migliorie viviamo in un paese che non è
riuscita a far diminuire gli infortuni
sul lavoro
è come una guerra
migliorano le leggi migliorano le
tecnologie migliorano gli strumenti e
facciamo sempre più morti gli ultimi
anni sono stati da record nei primi otto
mesi del 2022 ci sono stati
677 infortuni mortali
infortuni mortali
vedete guardatevi attorno
in questo teatro saremo più o meno in
Beh è come se dall'inizio dell'anno
fossero crollati tre di questi teatri
senza lasciar scappa nessuno
l'anno scorso ci sono stati oltre 480
mila infortuni sul lavoro e il contatore
dei morti sotto i colpi dell'insicurezza
si è fermato a 1.361 vittime
1361 famiglie che hanno perso un papà
una mamma
un figlio una figlia un fratello una
sorella
un marito o una moglie
di fronte a questi numeri da guerra
siamo tutti d'accordo che Qualcosa deve
cambiare ma come
esistono diverse risposte a questa
domanda vi racconto la mia utilizzo il
marketing una mia passione mescolandolo
la sicurezza sul lavoro
Attenzione però i lavoratori sono
persone non sono dei numeri e come
persone si lasciano influenzare da
sensazioni emozioni percezioni durante
l'attività lavorativa e la formazione
Quindi qual è secondo voi il segreto per
creare un legame con i lavoratori e allo
stesso tempo alzare il livello di
sicurezza
la parola magica empatia
l'empatia è quella qualità che ti
permette di entrare in sintonia con la
persona che hai davanti Qualunque essa
sia e farla sentire a proprio agio
Quanti di voi conoscono il marketing
empatico lo so che il marketing sembra
strano da sentire perché quella
strategia che usano le aziende per
venderci loro prodotti e servizi Ma se
io prendessi quelle tecniche e le
utilizzassi per convincere i lavori i
lavoratori a compiere delle azioni che
possano salvare loro la vita
permetterei A tante famiglie di restare
insieme intere
e allora ho capito che dovevo cambiare
qualcosa dovevo cambiare il mio modo di
comunicare la sicurezza sul lavoro e il
marketing il geometra mazza mi hanno
sempre insegnato che dovevo parlare la
stessa lingua delle persone che avevo
davanti
ci siete
e allora ho capito Il segreto
semplificare semplificare e semplificare
questo deve essere il mio compito il
nostro compito e l'ho voluta mettere
ripetuto tre volte perché semplificano
le aule semplificano i cantieri e
semplifico sui social volete vedere come
Quanti di voi hanno uno smartphone
le utilizzate le Emoji
sono quei disegnini che dal 2008 ci
permettono con un'immagine di raccontare
tutto
Prendetevi due secondi vedete
caro lavoratore mentre lavori puoi
morire
se non usi il cervello Semplice no
non abbiamo bisogno di articoli Commi
decreti che fino ad ora con i lavoratori
hanno funzionato poco potrebbe essere
sufficiente ricordare loro che sono
anche dei genitori e hanno a casa i
bambini che li aspettano e usando il
cervello possono tornare a preparare la
cena quella sera
Eppure però ci sono delle persone
temerarie che non hanno proprio voglia
di indossare le protezioni Allora
prendete il loro elmetto e loro giubbino
E scrivete le frasi dei loro figli vi
garantisco che vorranno tornare a casa
come nel caso di Atena
Atena fa la magazziniera e per tutto il
giorno e sposta il rischio di essere
investita dai carrelli elevatori
ma non è solo questo il rischio Atena
tre figlie che sono particolarmente
tristi Quando mamma esce di casa per
andare a lavorare la mattina un po' come
tutti i bambini no
chiudete gli occhi
chiudeteli provate ad immaginare quanto
potrebbero essere tristi le file di
Atena se mamma non tornasse più a casa
per un mancato gilet
oppure Salvatore
Salvatore fa il muratore e per tutto il
giorno è soggetto a forti rumori in
cantiere rumori che alla lunga gli
rovineranno l'udito perché ho sempre
fatto così anche se per legge dovrebbe
indossare le protezioni
qualche tempo fa Salvatore mi raccontava
di sua figlia Alice che è stata appena
selezionata per un famoso concorso
canoro per ragazzini e che da grande
vuole fare la cantante allora gli ho
detto Caro Salvatore
vuoi continuare ad ascoltare tua figlia
Anche quando sarà grande
Ascolta un consiglio indossa Queste
cuffie
vedete la prevenzione degli Infortuni e
la sicurezza sul lavoro possono essere
dei temi molto difficili pesanti noiosi
oppure possono essere semplificati
colorati di Emoji e raccontate ai
lavoratori attraverso le emozioni dei
loro cari
siete d'accordo con me
fantastico ed è per questo che qualche
lavoratore ha cominciato a
soprannominarmi influencer della
sicurezza perché alla fine del corso si
è divertita Ho imparato qualcosa di
nuovo in modo semplice e diretto e
allora grazie a questi feedback ho
ideato un termine tutto particolare
l'avete già sentito Safety un influencer
sono io i miei colleghi e lo sono tutte
le persone che hanno il coraggio di
influenzare gli altri a seguire la
sicurezza sul lavoro e di conseguenza a
pensare al loro futuro la u sta per
utile non convenzionale oppure perché
l'ho fatto per te Uh come io
mi hanno invitato qui per raccontarvi
questo mio progetto e queste mie idee
affinché vi possano ispirare per
semplificare aiutare e salvare migliaia
di lavoratori
Pensateci tutto quello che farete da
domani potrà fare la differenza tra la
vita e la morte grazie
[Applauso]